but if this little commercial break from
the episode does anything please
understand the only person you need
permission from is yourself i'm tripoli
given a pedigree beam and a special my
specialty of putting the words tuesday
morning back on the grind so nice
weekend I haven't taken a Monday
Presidents Day my entire career so it's
fun but as the kids get older what a
weekend more time hacking always adjust
you know that is a that has been the
absolute pillar of my success which is
if I decide tomorrow that I'm anti
hustle and it's all about laying on the
beach and sending out mentally
[Music]
I'm not scared scared change my tune
obviously there's a big difference
between changing and breaking your word
talk about that yesterday's episode but
excited the weather looks good this week
it's pretty cool
it should be a nice grinding week he's a
hectic day I'm a way to go see David
Levy president Turner Broadcasting
incredible guy one of my favorite
executives really one of the more
entrepreneurial senior executives that
I've come across just willing to do
stuff and and that's why he's had a
great career salesman at heart that oh
he speaks to me I think we need to
expand on more and Darius salesmanship
one of biggest reasons I'm pushing 2017
flip challenges I genuinely believe that
whether you're 60 or 16 or 90 or 19 that
learning how to sell is one of the
incredible advantages in running a
business in your whole life so much of
my career has been being so great at
sales that I was able to wait for the
market to come to me a lot of strategies
and things I believe in are futuristic
or three to five years away what do you
do before everybody wants to spend on
Facebook what do you do before everybody
wants to spend on social media what do
you do before everybody wants to drink
Spanish and Australian wines what do you
do what you do is you find a few people
that are actually out there willing to
buy when things I talk a lot about is
not selling to the unsellable right you
know if somebody's not willing to buy
you've got no shot and so these are some
of the patterns so I find myself always
attracted to sales people hobby nobody's
around everybody still off today yeah
got it but the city seems quiet
[Music]
and then just to have us all lined me
you and the one or two people or three
whatever's in the trenches and then we
can go and then we can have kind of a a
weekly kind of 10-minute call meeting in
the office 10-15 minutes just to keep me
somewhat abreast to it that's the real
problem when people kind of figure it
out yeah he's he's got it
best city in the world
so man how are you my name is Muhammad
Muhammad excellent rate to show you some
sample thank you my friend check it out
I will I will let me picture a car
the one question that I have is like
did you make the transition I know you
are selling wine yes and how do you make
that transition from selling physical
product to like being a personal yeah
just takes time you know everybody sees
me now yeah but in 2000 you know in 1999
98 you know how old are you 25 just keep
doing it for five years you'll be a
young man and it'll be there it's
patience I mean it when I say patience
I know Prasad believed that nice to me
just not a charity Allister
holy s--t rise up here Iron Man is there
pleasure take care thank you thank you
minutes that's right hey morning Sabra
split ends hey what's up caddy yeah you
give me my first customer for my beanie
company I'm definitely doing it I'm
gonna launch I'm gonna launch a beanie
brand 100% 100% just feel like I love
wearing them so much I want to have like
summer ones to like that are thinner a
culture hacker I mean that's what I'm
doing like I'm pretty like raped I like
that's what I'm winning on I'm hanging
out with rappers who are two years away
from being famous I'm put and when I see
blood in the water like Instagram I go
all-in and then everybody's like how did
you get so much more famous in three
months it's cuz I had that moment like a
truck along a truck along a truck along
and then I have a moment it's kind of
how I think about the influential
Facebook thing get me three names ASAP
hey guys
Hey hello hey I'm a your life form do
you believe it I think it's an
interesting term it's funny that you
brought that up it's starting to hit my
radar it's been asked about a lot more
lately I I think it's a good one
I think that I hate fake it to the make
to make it in the way that it's
happening now which is people are just
talking [ __ ] on social and truly faking
it like there's dudes that legitimately
rent everything from watches cars
vacation house and girls to paint the
picture to the outside world on their
social I hate that strategizing your
next step so while they think you're
listening to Kanye you are taking the
next move
I think faking it - you're making it
inside of your own head which is you're
you're you're constantly pushing
yourself and you believe in yourself and
you're realistic about where you are
that's why I brought up document over
you know you know creating like if you
guys are like hey we're two young
entrepreneurs we're hustling we're just
starting the journey of this of this
podcast of this blog of this thing it's
way cooler than you guys saying like
we're doing it like like that's what
everybody's doing like the second they
put CEO or entrepreneur in their
Instagram they start trying to act it
and they think taking a selfie with like
one of the sharks on shark tank proves
it I think it's important for people to
know that even at my level like to spend
a second just say thank you and I just
really appreciate it you're crushing
[Music]
she was my mentor so she taught me so
much I just think it's your work ethic
as well they're just really impressive
to me it's such a big thing for me
anyway I just really genuinely wanted to
steal a minute of your time and let you
know it's on my radar it's on the
organization's radar and if there's
anything I can ever do for you or answer
for you I'm here yes yes yes really yes
yes yes yes yep yes sir yep
but good news it's only a millennial
thing because Milenio sort of young
generation now it was a Gen X thing it
was a baby boomer thing when you're
young you're impatient patience is
always my model like if you guys
actually all four of you [ __ ]
understood how young you guys were and
how much time you actually had if I the
new thing and I've said this once or
twice is if I could let all four of you
feel how I feel right now like how young
I feel how much more time I have like
out like where I'm going like the youth
I feel in my soul you guys would change
you would change everything you do if
you you know if you guys knew how much
like it would change everything because
then you would get really [ __ ]
patient you'd be really calculated you'd
really build real good building blocks
for something serious all right really
good man so we're gonna pleasure how's
it going so far yeah it's good good yeah
it's busy how long you been here now
good yeah
you enjoying it yeah it is it's really
interesting
that's a whole different and you should
use this meeting as a permission to ping
me anytime I want to interact with the
company often so I'm always here yeah
ad-hoc on email like hey why is this
happening or like this for 5-10 minutes
or hey can I once a year get a drink
with you for 40 minutes yeah I mean I
don't think people understand how
important a cue and culture culture is
being thrown around like
entrepreneurship well correct correct
yes correct
so for me I take both very seriously and
I think that's why we're getting the
results on both fronts yeah it's a great
day all right I'll talk to you soon yeah
because when it's my wife watches it my
son Luke that is my son Luke watches
this so you gonna make a big cameo I'm
you already made a quickly little one
the other day in our dinner some very
I've yet to watch it daily I watched it
about once a week I'll take it
thank you for the very start it's unreal
start I say to myself oh my god is he
signing more books I'm looking at all
these logos and emblems you guys like
[Music]
[Music]
there we go
how are you man that's exactly right and
not only that the reason I replied
because I would never waste your time is
I genuinely believe that meditations the
next enormous consumer space that in the
same way that Starbucks took over coffee
in the same way that SoulCycle Equinox
just kind of like the physical health
revolution back to what you and I talked
about over the last 20-30 years that in
ten years every single American is
spending real money on mental fitness
[Music]
so so I think a lot of the creative is
out of our hands until those are out and
we have some dollars left over for the
amplification and the micro moments and
the cutting room floor that's where I
think the manor proper la can have a
little say got it have insights to the
names of the alternatives of the names
they gave us so it's creatively on par
we should leave next week with a good
idea creatively of what we're doing with
my main video and who are the top 10
targets to be the other four faces of
the brand yeah I don't I don't want it
out so this is where it needs to die
obviously some other people know so if
Juliet whatever left make sure nobody
talks about it okay thanks guys
thank you
[Music]
vaynernation
both my posts today like I can't get off
this kick just ranting right now talking
straight to camera who the [ __ ]
permission are you looking for like it's
either your brother I can't believe how
many you mean with me like everybody
just looking for a nudge like you need
to figure that out within yourself like
this is literally literally like jumping
in the pool and swimming for the first
time or like skydiving for the first
time or kissing a boy for the first time
like this is all the same [ __ ] like
having sex for the first time like
proposing like having a child living the
life that you want for yourself is the
biggest version of all those things and
it is my dream that my content creates
that for you but I'm scared that I'm not
gonna get to most of you I'm scared that
I'm not gonna get to most of you and I'm
scared that even the ones that are
giving me their attention right now I
haven't been able to penetrate yet
because I have to talk in generalities
because I don't know you I won't get the
serendipity of being in front of you but
if this little commercial break from the
episode does anything please understand
the only person you need permission from
is yourself
for feeding
something secretly friends the day of
hustle feel really good the electricity
of the action keeps me going forever I
wish on you the love of the game that I
have for my game
and
[Music]
[Music]